ah yes again mister what a gas haven't
played him before quite a while so what
do we do against him I really you should
do something else can I get some kind of
mayhem going it's really difficult time
it's really difficult to get him out of
his comfort zone maybe I can play some
some touch him yeah he knows his stuff
t5 is a bit unusual but probably not bad
at all what do I do now Knight c5 and
maybe I'm just making up things as I go
along
I'm not really an expert on the
Leningrad Dutchman no he's afraid of
checkmate some he really is wants to
stop f4 I mean okay that's not I'm not
making fun of him I understand it's not
a bad decision probably okay let's take
it if he takes g5 f5 is hanging this is
not good this is not good at all
I can jump to e4 now however 97 is a
move anyway let's do it at least this is
kind of confusing and probably for both
of us
Knight to c7 yeah rook c8 might be six
maybe and it's a weird position not a
good one probably for me but it is weird
it is a weird one cheeks he wants to
check their take on g5 and then take on
f5 something like this can I somehow
sacrifice stuff here to make him but if
I do this Knight c8 and takes on g3 this
is totally crazy but let's do it
it's not totally totally off I mean I
hope
Knight c8 I take on g3 so he was not
really up for that I'm gonna be keeping
the Snow Queen cigs I guess yeah a very
strange position night p5 is probably
his idea somehow I'd be five Queenie Sam
it shouldn't be too bad I need to get
out of that D foul this is fine when d6
put the co2 I don't get it really or is
it just as usual mo can trade everything
and hope for the best
yeah we do look worthless rook probably
that's really the case
he really very often doesn't have any
other idea but it is effective as he is
quick and it's not peace not blundering
stuff sorry my voice is a little bit a
little bit feeding me yeah getting in b5
would be cute but he's got 94 I guess
oh it's a 5 a movie our sis this is far
too weakening let's let's do that nope
nothing too long if I get to take I kept
96 and I can attack that pawn it's not
so easy to keep it that doesn't look too
bad actually this pollution
maybe night h4 and
no mine that I can take like g8 that's
that's good for me I've got work till
5:00 maybe night H form this move
that's a related idea that's related
idea fatigue and ninety-six
an ith form
and you threatening to take that twice
interesting just cookie eight I don't
know I should have played that quicker I
mean this was definitely a playable one
maybe not the best move but it is
playable rook f3 might be an idea now I
can know then he takes on you for
interesting
okay three is really coming here
time morning yeah you played that well I
guess not just some time just well
played
yeah I am there didn't see it but it was
a bad position I played that really
really well with root d5 Knight h4 and
so on
I cannot cover at five now I mean
decently let's say I'm at 65 and I
predict played that well black resigns
I really had said some hopes there that
I have a good position don't they have a
good position probably not rooty fibers
really strong yeah then he 5 is a bad
idea
I mean yeah I'm okay I'm pretty sure my
kingís is playing and I don't really
have any particular problem him the
engine wants to go d5 and gives like a
slight advantage hmm the alch 84 is a
threat slight edge but okay maybe 96 and
the depandi point is rather dangerous my
king is more active true well that might
be right
I was a bit I was playing for this but
Rock d5 is really strong that's a really
strong move the problem is like him he
has this threat and it's just immensely
strong well it's very strong I have
nothing against that and I have also
have no move this is a big problem here
he's threatening fe5 and they have no
move that wasn't helping at all and this
is really bad him but I was simply
running out of moves here I have nothing
the engine wants to play b5 this is in
fact maybe a good practical idea at
least but it won't help me objectively
speaking now I played that well from
here after a 5 that was good d5 55
I mean after d5 I'm certainly okay em I
was even thinking about this but this is
probably too strong I can too strong a
me too
too aggressive it's the right way to put
it now if abruptly five is good young
that's really good
he has to play that also if he doesn't I
mean here I can take again yes they say
this is what I had seen hmm now if I've
is not good
amazingly looked if fire interesting
yeah okay I played that well I mean I
don't mind losing against him in this
this way I mean if you plays well no
problem just look against Lucas kind of
stupid okay well thanks for watching